look for everybody in the crowd we're in
this moment right now 98 of nft projects
that are in the market right now are
gonna go to zero
or close to it like we're in a very
unique time this is very similar to
internet public stocks in 1999 where the
internet was right but we all got ahead
of ourselves and we put 40 billion
valuations on companies that hadn't even
sold anything on the internet yet and it
crashed in march and april of 2000
that's what's happening in the nft world
right now
you've got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
[Music]
as normal i did a lot of research
although michael i know you very well
i'm going to start with gary vee uh just
my like the things i've been listening
to is books on audible um and there's
very little content out there right not
a lot of content hard to find um serial
entrepreneur tech investor social media
extravaganza he predicted the influencer
economy and then has driven it he's the
author of five best sellers uh which
i've been listening to most recently
12.5 which is just fantastic he turned
the book publishing industry upside down
when he connected the launch of it with
uh with nfts garyvee's are
just killing it it's amazing thank you
michael i'm going to start with a quote
from sbj just so we have a little bit of
perspective few people over the past 14
months this was a in january of this
year have done more to rethink the
traditional ways of doing business and
aggressively changing the status quo
than michael rubin seemingly not just
making money for fanatics but also the
partners and of course the leagues
you are named as the most influential
person in sports this year by sbj you're
a regular on cnbc
uh you've grown fanatics scratch it out
18 billion to 27 billion announced
yesterday leaked yesterday and your
focus on evolving the leading e-commerce
company to the leading sports digital
company
so let's get started you guys are so
impactful i love it
i want to talk about how you two got
started um during well
got started with your candy digital and
that concept so during the pandemic you
co-founded and collaborated on the
all-in challenge which raised over 60
million dollars for charity by
auctioning off experiences with
celebrities how did working together on
in lead to candy digital
okay so you know from my perspective
gary is always someone who's like 17
steps ahead and you know this could be
the first time i'm really giving them uh
public credit for it but the whole
trading card idea that fanatics you know
has built a pretty big business around
came from gary hitting me over the head
about 17 000 times saying um you need to
be in trading cards it's the next big
asset class this is going to be gigantic
and when we did the all-in challenge
together guy was talking to me about
kind of you know where the nft market
could head so gary's a guy who i always
value that i have in my kind of orbit of
seeing trends first recognizing big
opportunities and um you know i knew
gary pretty well going into the
challenge but the the 24 7 mentality
that he brought toward doing whatever it
took to you know raise much money for
people with food and security was
amazing and it just made me love him
even that much more and returned
obviously doing something good for the
world into creating new business
together
you know i think
one of the unique things about michael
is there's very few people who
have
the combo of
sizzle and steak when you have charisma
or energy or creativity
a lot of times the operational execution
part doesn't come along with that and
vice versa and there are unique
individuals that come along that can
really combine the two and and the same
thing for me i had an incredible uh
point of view on who michael was but
really having somebody actually keep up
with me 24 hours a day felt so unique
and i was like okay this guy's on a on a
different plane all and you know
we were navigating our own businesses
and our own family situations
in coven and
listen co-founding is being incredibly
kind michael called me and already had
it baked and said hey do you want to
help me with this and i just remember
that phone call because it was very
early in the process and things were
still very scary and i was like the
humanity to try to help others while
navigating the things he had to do
really really struck me and and
definitely changed our relationship
i love that and i i love your comment
about the sizzle with the operations
because michael you have a long-standing
relationship with mlb
and so as you as you were conceiving of
candy digital
um how which was announced in june 21
how uh how how do you think
first
how that
how that relationship with mlb
is changing the way we think of baseball
well first i think you know
relationships are everything and you
know in business you need to have both
great strategy
um and great relationships to make that
strategy happen so you know we work with
today close to a thousand
sports properties globally and you know
baseball is an incredible partnership
and i think you know what we saw was an
amazing you know i think what gary saw
and what gary helped me see quite
honestly was an amazing
um you know
long-term opportunity but also one that
would go through a lot of changes and so
when we spoke to baseball the
conversation was really about how do we
build this the right way for the fan
long term and i think you know the nft
market really started going around the
crypto community and what you know gary
helped me understand and i think what we
understood early was it was not only
about the crypto community but it's
really about how do we get billions of
sports fans to engage with nfts and you
know really engage with
with with incredible content that all
the sports properties possess long term
and so baseball really want to build the
right way and what was terrific about
the way we started the business they
said look
we want to do this with you
make sure you take care of our fan make
sure you build this the right way long
term they were actually less worried
about money knowing that they built this
the right way the dollars would follow
the most important thing for them was
building up for the fan long term
and so gary with all of your expertise
how did you help accelerate what what
michael was thinking about what fanatics
was thinking about with candy digital
any specific examples yeah i mean look
for everybody in the crowd we're in this
moment right now 98 percent of nft
projects that are in the market right
now are going to go to zero
or close to it like we're in a very
unique time this is very similar to
internet public stocks in 1999 where the
internet was right but we all got ahead
of ourselves and we put 40 billion
dollar valuations on companies that
hadn't even sold anything on the
internet yet and it crashed in march and
april of 2000
that's what's happening in the nft world
right now
there's so much money being thrown
around so much greed
so much short-term behavior that
almost every project that we see out
there even if it's already done 10-20
million dollars in sales
is incredibly vulnerable because the ip
creator the the founders of these
projects are genuinely not building it
with the long tail in mind and so
you know whether it was the way we
thought about sweet futures which is one
of the things we do in candy which was
you know with nil
changing the landscape right of college
sports we were able to really put
together opportunities that for the fan
that was buying the nft
i think one thing that is completely
being missed right now is in 20 years
people are going to care
what the rookie nft is when's the first
time this person showed up on the
blockchain no different than when was
the first time that somebody showed up
on a piece of cardboard or the first
time they showed up in a comic book and
so a lot of what we've done at candy is
give a lot of strategies to how do we
put people that we think will be
long-term superstars on the blockchain
first and how do we structure the
rarities
what is the supply and demand i mean the
reality is it's the only thing that i'm
paying attention to when i work with the
team at candy which is is this
strategically set up to be a long-term
win that creates secondary behaviors and
value for the original buyers
and i think that it's all
classic collectible supply and demand
strategies of that nature and so
literally every launch you know i want
to go back to what he just said because
um
i think gary's 100 right um to make a
prediction and gary's often uh if you
look at his predictions years later um
they're often very accurate to say 98 of
the nft projects are going to go to zero
it's you know i've been saying something
very similar which is there's going to
be a giant crash in this market coming
and i actually love that gary's talking
about because you also need to look at
just like the law of like logic and you
know today you have so much new content
coming every day and um you know to me
um that's why you know candy what we've
thought about is how do we build this
the right way the long the
long term the right way and how do we
make sure that we build great content
for for sports fans and great products
that are going to increase in value for
sports fans and if you don't i actually
think uh we're actually hurting the the
the different sports properties we work
with we're hurting fans and so um but
what gary said you know i think it's
going to be true so you know today when
you look out the market so many people
think this is just easy money it's just
going to go up and i think you're going
to find a lot of people it's just going
to be like the internet crash that gary
talked about in 1999 or the financial
crash that we went through in 2008 it's
coming into the nft market there's no
way with the amount of new content
that's coming on that this can go
straight up it's and i'm sorry to jump
in but i think the big thing for this
crowd is
understanding that that's when it gets
interesting
right because again if you look like i
think what's going to happen is it's
going to crash and the media is going to
have a field day told you told you told
you told you you can read unlimited
articles in the summer of 2000 saying we
told you the internet was a fad we told
you the reality is the consumer
blockchain is the single biggest
technology shift since the internet
itself it is that profound every ticket
to every sporting event in a decade is
going to be an nft the technology is too
obvious
but the x the macro is unbelievable the
micro executions right now are cliche
gold rush and what we've generally seen
in fanatics by the way is
on the way up you build a lot of things
organically on the way down you find
ways to um add m a into kind of an
accelerated building look we went
through this even you know in covert we
did so many things to you know
accelerate our business because there
were so many companies that weren't
prepared to kind of live through cove
and i think in every crash um there's so
many opportunities for you know good
strong companies to have the right
long-term vision the most important
thing is you get the strategy right if
you get the strategy right um you know
then you can think more thoughtfully
about the timing and right now
there are a lot of things that don't
make sense but they don't make sense you
know you can be strategically right with
your business plan but that doesn't mean
you act until you know things kind of
come your way so two great points there
let's talk about that strategy and i
think i want to highlight gary what you
did with v friends
and
which has been massively successful for
those of you who don't know
right now there was one that was
auctioned for as high as 1.2 million uh
and the lowest current value of it is of
one is 30k so what did you do
to bring branding and generate over 91
million dollars in the first 90 days and
then i do want to come back to
blockchain but i want to start with some
of those strategies well the thing that
is most fascinating to me about the
blockchain and one and a lot of my
friends reached out to me when i went so
hard and they're like man i've watched
you for 15 years leave so much money on
the table to preserve your reputation
why are you
ruining it now basically is what they
were saying you're doing something so
high risk and i'm and i said to them
said you don't understand the blockchain
it's actually the reverse
if you are the creator of a project an
nft project you're actually more in
control
than anything that has ever happened
before let me explain with v friends
first i use the utility of the smart
contract to create a three-year promise
contract of a conference called vcon
that i'm doing at u.s bank stadium in
minnesota in may
which you know it's it's a profound
lineup of every of the who's who
michael's even coming and i don't think
he's ever been to minnesota and so like
you know it's you know it is cold there
i am aware you
thank you um
the you know and so
first i think people are not using the
utility aspect of nfts enough right now
right now we're in the art and
collectible phase no different than the
internet 94 we were in the information
age right the internet's awesome for
information the internet was awesome for
information it was also going to do so
many more things in our society the
blockchain right now is on art and
collectibles but it's a contract and so
i did a three-year conference i did a
lot of access tokens um where zooms like
information things that people actually
value besides the collectible
but the part that i was referring to
earlier and this is why i wanted to be
in business you know candy's really the
only other major thing i'm really
involved in
is that i knew how
michael thought about the consumer
let me just paint the picture for
everybody who's hesitant to do an nft
project because they actually are good
people and they fear that the value goes
down
with with
candy with me friends if god forbid the
market crashes and some you know it's
one thing for all the people that spent
two thousand dollars for it last may and
are selling it for 30 40 70 100 000 they
did great but what about the guy or girl
who bought it today for 40 000 and the
market goes to 8 000. for me
because it's on the blockchain i can
provide more value for that person
you're the central bank you're the
country you're in control so i just you
know i've been telling a lot of my
friends who i think have not the best
behavior in mind who are going to be
like well they made it you know they
bought it they took a risk i'm like it
works a little bit different you're in
control of that economy and your
reputation is completely tied in so i
think for the people that have good
intent and have resources and are smart
for me
i take a lot of usd off the table with
my project
and put it in one place just for the
rainy day so i can deploy that capital
back to the people that own v friends
and i think the best projects will do
that and
just for the audience you use the word
utility yes and that means that there's
something of value that you're creating
that is going with the nft so access or
the sporting ticket
is the ticket but the but the utility is
getting into the venue but god willing
somebody drops 100 points that night and
and ties will chamberlain that becomes
an instant asset
and even when you when you when you take
that to candy and gary has had huge
influence to the products that are
created at candy you know i sat in
meeting with gary a few months ago and
you know in two seconds gary comes up
with an idea okay we're going to do you
know a new collection of rookie products
and in these rookie products we're gonna
have um you know face times available
with you know all the 101s or you know
and look in sports you have the ability
to create and really i think in many
places you have the ability to create
great uh experiential value and that's
what gary's talking about i think we
have a great opportunity to do that as
well and i think you know gary's point
he's always thinking about how to create
something that's got real value versus
there are a lot of people just like you
know they're kind of you know fast and
loose and trying to make a quick buck
they're not thinking about you know how
does this play long term and certainly
for a company like fanatics it's you
know you know getting to be a decent
sized company you know we you know we
think about you know most importantly
how do we do the right thing for the
sports fan long term we want to have
billions of fans local thenx as a
beloved company everything that we do
needs to create a great experience for
them if it doesn't it actually hurts our
brand and so and we don't do everything
right by the way we screw things up
every day but you know we think about
most importantly like how do we have
billions of fans that look at fanatics
as a beloved company where they get most
of their digital products from us and so
you know with candy we need to create
you know not only a great product but we
need to figure out all the things we can
do to enhance that product and you have
to think long term for all the people
that are deeper into this space you go
into the discords where these
communities live with these projects
every day everyone's like what about the
fourth place make the floor price go up
everyone is such a day trader right now
i see a lot of founders
succumbing to the energy of their
discord their discord is in a community
their discord are day traders who want
to make a quick dollar and you know i
think what i'm really proud of with be
friends and with candy is
listen we care deeply about what
everybody who's holding an nft thinks
but like a parent we're willing to do
the short-term unpopular for the
long-term win
so i'm gonna switch off of uh
nft's cryptos and blockchain i wanna
talk about analytics
and i'm gonna start with you um gary i
said i've been listening to your book on
audio and obviously analytics is core to
what we do
um well you started your the book just
and i thought it was amazing i shared it
with my children and my wife but you
said um
facts about gratitude to help us feel so
728 million people in the world do not
have drinking water 60
of people in the world don't have a
toilet that manages human waste and so
data is big in what you do you're
helping all of us think like that from
an analytical perspective
can you share how you and your team
over the last decade have used
social content and constantly evolve
your strategy and maybe one specific
example that will resonate for people
you know it's funny obviously being in
the epicenter
at this event i have historically been a
much
more
passionate qual
data guy than quant data guy but you use
data a lot i use data every second right
and i think that you know for me even
going back to launching an e-commerce
swine business in 1996
i remember making talk about making
mistakes i was innovating oh you know
shopping cart abandonment and all these
things just naturally because i just
wanted people to buy the wine
that went on to become the industry
standard practices i wish i built some
sas businesses around my behavior i
could have done
well but you know i think you're doing
okay well hang in i think the reality is
is that
um
i look at it every day i mean for
example
i'll give you an example of how we think
about in the last decade one of the
things that i'm very proud of is i
believe that i have day traded
the public's attention
extremely well over the last decade
um i feel that on a daily basis my
number one objective before i fill that
bucket
with whatever i'm passionate about is
where are all of their eyes and ears
every second and that comes through
analytics for me
my
my
north star being everyone's attention
allows me three and a half years ago to
tell everybody in my companies and every
business that i'm associated with that
we have to get very serious about tick
tock it's not because i'm guessing
it's because the math is very clear i
can see that people are moving their
time spent the account growth
the comment count and then more
importantly when i layer qualitative
around the quant and see the affinity is
very high and i see that people are
going all in on the interest graph not
just the social graph
and then i'm ready to kind of move and
so on a daily basis i'm curious about
the organic reach and the cost of media
on linkedin youtube facebook twitter
instagram snapchat
spotify and any other
platform that will amass hundreds of
millions of users on it and then every
individual execution in it you know it
doing great on instagram has required
analytical movement from the picture
gets the most organic reach to the video
gets the most organic reach to now it's
a reels that you put in feed not just as
a real and so on a daily basis it is the
framework of everything that's awesome
all right so i'm gonna talk analytics
with you uh and you you have been in it
um you champion
the 80 million customers that you have
i'm sure it's growing by the second
um what do you really know about them
michael yeah and yeah yeah well first i
think the thing that actually took us
like i always like to look back and see
what we got right and wrong the thing
that was actually a great eye-opening
experience for us is we spent you know
kind of nearly a decade building our
first business which was really the
merchandise business we caught finance
commerce we woke up and we realized we
had a huge structural advantage to
building the leading digital sports
platform when we think about how to
create all these different digital
sports businesses um really our brand
and our database were the most two
important assets that we had and our
database we we know so much about
each of our fans we probably have today
between 50 and 60 attributes on average
per fan we can really use that to to
really improve the experience and now
when you think about it that we're going
from our first business of merchandise
and now we're adding trading cards and
nfts and and online sports betting and
over time media the ability to uh really
use data to really
personalize the experience and make the
experience for each digital spritz fan
so much better is a great opportunity
for us i'd say it's probably you know
the biggest advantage we have and
there's really not if you really think
about it there's really not another
company that wakes up and goes to bed
obsessed with how to improve the digital
sports fan experience and um you know i
think data is really at the core of
everything that we do uh and obviously
look you can't even build a merchandise
business with that you know look our
merchandise business this year is four
and a half billion dollars the original
business we started in um and you can't
build that without data being quote
everything we do but when you think
about now how we you know build this
digital sports platform you know the the
again the biggest structural advantage
we have is the database and the ability
to use that to you know help improve the
experience for each fans ultimately it
gives us a reduced marketing cost as
well we go out and we now acquire you
know a fan in um the commerce business
and that fans gonna you know buy trading
cards from us and and buy empties from
us and and do online sports betting with
us and do really each of the different
businesses that we have so it's it's a
huge advantage of one that keeps getting
better every day when i think one of the
things that i have learned from watching
you is the vertical integration that you
do and so you've gone down which you've
done on the commerce side and now you're
going broad across right and taking that
which is you know obviously amazing and
the 50 to 60 attributes is going to grow
because you have these other businesses
so it's it's really brilliant so
obviously yesterday it was announced 27
billion
valuation and you raised 1.5 what are
the 1.5 billion just so we're clear what
are some of the key things that you're
thinking about in using that investment
for
yeah you know you know for us first of
all we don't really you know we're
thinking about how to build you know
that you know a company that's beloved
by billions of sports fans globally and
ultimately you know i think you know
evaluation just follows the business
results you know i think you know for us
you know one thing is very unique about
us is i've been screaming the way gary
screams about things uh and i think
people eventually you know listen i've
been screaming for years that you need
growth with profits and so as a company
uh we've been one that's been focused on
you know growing quickly doing great
things for the sports fan but also
making money the entire way and so for
us all the money we raise is really from
uh it's really to be used from a m a
perspective to go out and buy pieces to
kind of build our digital sports
platform more quickly so you know this
year alone we acquire tops um the
trading card company which is you know
kind of the most well-known brand of
trading cards to really enable a trading
card strategy to pull forward four years
we just acquired mitchell ness a few
weeks ago and so we like when we have a
strategy if we can buy pieces to kind of
move more quickly and so that's what we
use all the capital that we raised for
and we're going to look as a company
this year we were you know you know
profitable last year generate real free
cash flow we'll do it again this year in
a in a greater extent but all that money
gets invested either in how do we
enhance the fan experience globally or
how do we you know kind of buy
capabilities to do the same thing
i love it all right we're going to
switch a little bit to personal brand
you guys both have pretty big personal
brands gary you're the master of it
so uh how do you assess michael's brand
that's definitely pretty screwed up for
sure where is it and gary's responsible
for everything i've ever done wrong for
sure
where is he strong and where can he
improve
i i think michael's greatest strength is
his self-deprecation
i i think if you look at his content
there's a lot to make fun of me about
when he shares like videos of him
playing basketball um that just sets the
world on fire there's there's well you
should tell me when the big idea you
just pitched me on just about 15 minutes
ago i i told michael i i so i'm a big
believer that um nostalgia is incredibly
underpriced and so for a long time
especially with the emergence of betting
uh i've
long thought that there was an
opportunity for an ott
to come out called the prop network
where you would establish
these uh environments i said to michael
back stage i said imagine how many
people would tune into a pay-per-view of
magic johnson versus larry bird and
there was betting dynamics on top of it
well that's how you start you said i
know i'm about to go okay i think we
need to be honest um and i said you know
but the big one that i want to see is
you and dj khaled one on one i think we
can do i think we can do five million
pay-per-view um and so i i think what
michael you know for to be such a titan
of business for him to not take himself
serious to show the brighter side of him
he's a massive inspiration for a lot of
fathers out there with daughters with
his content this is stuff that people
don't talk about they don't see my my
what i do for a living is basically read
messages back to data i'm basically
a
human anthropologist and do qual data
all day long constantly even on the
flight here very early i'm reading
direct messages and comments and stuff
so i think what he does extremely well
we obviously see him with the the crafts
and the meek mills and all that stuff
that is so aspirational but i think if
you look carefully between the
self-deprecating nature of like hey yeah
i'm good at these things but i'm not as
great at these things and
just being an incredible dad
you see a big movement of dads tapping
into their you know being
dads of girls and there's a really great
movement on that i think he's doing a
phenomenal job on that what he's doing
poorly is
a lot of things um 26 minutes okay um
you know a couple things i think you
know our a lot of our friendship comes
of the building blocks over the last
decade
sage knows like every time i would come
across michael anywhere i'm like michael
you got to start making content he
hesitated on it in the same way that
many people here have not bought their
first nft yet that's just a massive
mistake whether you think it's a fad or
not to disregard an entire movement
is a mistake like you've got to taste it
uh even if you lose a thousand bucks
it's worth it that's the education
you've got to taste things when they're
innovating and so i think broadening
some of the platforms that he puts out
his content because he's gotten
comfortable with instagram but we need
him to
really expand his horizons gary who do
you think would win in the one-on-one
between khaled and i
i think khalid i agree i agree i think
he he would body you up he would use his
you know he would just get you down he
still might miss a three-footer he's you
guys are both atrocious
i'm gonna when i leave her i'm gonna
call him and get the challenge on it's
going to be for a private competition
but i'm going to do it i think i feel
inspired our next all-in challenge
should be those things where the all the
proceeds go to
a non-profit because i think people
would really enjoy that and i really
look you look at the big three you look
at some of these celebrity boxing
matches i think there's
a lot of
evolution still to be done in sports and
i think we're kind of like having a
laugh here but i think there's a lot of
opportunity in
people love competition yeah you know
like people love competition and people
fall in love with names and a lot of
times when these athletes retire or
these people in pop culture you know
meek mill making that shot the other day
right yeah i mean like that's stuff that
people are fairly interested in we
should be honest i actually took the
video hoping he was going to miss the
rim i know and that he actually went in
was actually really impressive
he was really lucky i posted that i was
really good it posed a bad outcome not a
good outcome but somehow uh the
basketball gods were with him
i i mean i love the banter so much and i
mean that's pretty good advice i enjoy
your content i think i personally like
the dancing the most uh but you have a
good uh some good coaching before that
competition
um so if you guys are thinking about the
influence that you could have and
potentially um you know raising more
funds as your brand your brand is
amazing obviously and you understand how
to do it great advice
what do you think
michael as your brand continues to to
rise in your awareness what are the
areas that you're most passionate about
in terms of continuing to influence yeah
so so the first thing i just want to go
back for a second because i think this
is kind of a good just everyone thinks
differently
gary consistently i love to have people
around me that i learn and grow from
it's like the big thing i always say
like i barely i think people know this
about my story but i barely met at high
school i didn't go to college so all of
my learning goes from getting um you
know just you know a diverse group of
friends that you know you can learn from
and we all learn from each other you
know sitting in the front rows robert
kraft who you know i consider to be my
younger and more
less responsible brother and you know i
learned i learned from robert every day
and gary i learned from you but gary's
always been he's always been um you know
ahead of me in a lot of things he talked
to me about trading cards years before
he got in the business he talked to me
about nmt's before we got into business
for years he harassed me to go on social
media like literally harassed me i mean
there wasn't a meeting where he didn't
scream me about why i'm an idiot you
need to be on social media it took me
probably four or five years later than
what he told me to do but the
interesting thing is one thing i believe
i actually really don't and people could
say this is [ __ ] but i'm just giving
it to you straight because that's my
personality i don't think about building
my brand i just do what's comfortable
what feels right to me and to me that's
the test i need to put things through so
there are a lot of things that that
people may say hey you should do this
but it just doesn't feel natural it
doesn't feel authentic and what the
things that i post are things that i
want to promote what we're doing with
the reformal criminal justice
organization we're building or i want to
you know promote something that that you
know dara mori is doing with the sixers
or that you know we're doing with the
basketball team i want to promote
something we're doing at fanatics or i
want to make fun of myself because
actually i do like making fun of myself
and it's very easy to do in those
moments every day to do that with her
you know i want to make fun of my
daughter and just have fun with her so
like i really put you know i kind of the
things i share with things that really
feel authentic to me and i don't like to
ever push the envelope and i sometimes
think for me less is more um i also i
look at a guy like gary and one of
things you know i love so much about him
is he's so motivational to everybody in
his energy is it it just he he he pulls
everyone with him and that's a great
thing and you know i think you know we
have a lot of similar traits we're also
very different you know i kind of you
know i motivate people in a different
way he motivates people a different way
but i think you know what's so
incredible about what gary's doing is
he's got you know tens of millions of
you know people that look at him and you
know who who who learn growing
and really most importantly are
motivated and he's you know showing tens
of millions of people how they can do
more do better and i think that's a
great impact to have for me when i think
about you know the question you really
asked which i'm not getting to which is
you know kind of you know what's the
influence we want to have going forward
look i am i wake up and go to bed
obsessed with how do i build you know
one of the most incredible companies in
the world i think you know it took me a
decade to kind of figure it out it's
kind of cool when you say look we
focused on building this you know you
know pretty respectable merchandise
business over the first 10 years but
then we realized we had a much bigger
opportunity that there literally are
billions of sports fans that we can
become their beloved brand where they do
everything digitally with us and so for
me you know i am 100 locked into doing
that and anything i do really you know i
want to support that initiative and that
you know kind of drive and and that
opportunity and you know everything else
around it's just things that maybe i'm
passionate about personally i mean you
both are very inspiring i mean i've
mentioned 12 and a half multiple times
it i mean it really is it's really it's
a great it's a great listen or read but
i've been linking to it so
um so thank you is he reading himself in
the in the in the book yeah at what
speed is it like a three-minute listing
because he does the whole book i don't
know what well what i like about it is
that he'll say okay i'm going to go off
script because i wrote this three months
ago i mean it's right this goes back to
day trading attention right like
things change every day yeah and so i
love doing the audio book because i do
get to do the remix yeah it's it's it's
great so uh we're gonna switch to
gambling now uh michael you mentioned
during the super bowl that you could you
believe you can be the number one player
in the space within 10 years um and
you're currently not in that business
so that's a bold statement what do you
think are your competitive advantages
over say draftkings and fanduel or
caesars or that way yeah so first off um
you know i actually as i get older and
that's happening very quickly you know
i'm i'm trying to be you know kind of
you know you try to want to be bold
internally and maybe a little less bold
externally although you want things to
rally people around so for me what i've
always had is a really big vision and
then you can like will things to happen
and if there's like the number one thing
about my personalities people always
tell me this can't be done this won't
happen i think that's like completely
[ __ ] like i think come up with a
really big dream come up with a really
big aspiration put a stake in the ground
just like figure out how you're gonna do
it and that has worked for me time after
time after time and by the way it's i'm
not doing on intellect i'm not doing it
on on books i'm definitely not doing
looks i'm definitely not doing on
physical physique i'm doing it on just
like drive and so you know to me when
you look at you know fanatics and
building this digital sports platform
you look and say today we've built you
know a nice and fast growing business in
our original you know model you know
finance commerce and we've now just come
and you know we're now kind of building
the trading card business pretty
aggressively now the nft business and
you look and say does online sports
betting fit into the digital sports
platform of fanatics i think 100 of
people look at that and say yes this is
like a perfect strategic fit then you
got to look and kind of assess the
market and um you know right now the
markets you know it's you know it's a
huge long-term opportunity but the
market's not making as much sense you
know in the near term and i've been
saying that pretty non-stop for last
last year so from my perspective i think
it's a perfect fit in our platform long
term i think we've got huge structural
advantages because we probably have the
most digitally oriented you know sports
commerce brand and we have this massive
database which gives us great structural
advantages and then we have um you know
we have the you know financial
wherewithal to you know kind of go after
things in an aggressive basis so you
know i you know i actually didn't mean
for that statement to come out publicly
i said it to somebody kind of in passing
but i do believe we will be the number
one player in the business in a decade
and i believe we'll do it through um
smart and aggressive um uh organic
growth and the structural advantages
that we have fanatics and then you know
m a will you know you know as we've done
in each of our businesses we've
generally had an aggressive organic plan
and then we've layered mergers and
acquisitions on top of it to find
businesses that fit well we'll do the
same thing here um and so this isn't a
business by the way today i got to tell
you something i mean the amount of money
that's being invested or lost if you
just put in simple english today is like
um you know it's you know there's money
being lit on fire if we keep it real uh
and that's and by the way we said that a
year ago i went to our board a year ago
and said look there's going to be a
massive space long term um and i said in
the near term you know i'm not quite
understanding the economics of this
business i generally try to make money
on things that we do it's a crazy
concept but you know when i look at
companies i like them to have a path to
profitability and like them to make
money and i think and look there there
are some great operators in this
business jason robins who runs
draftkings i love him i don't like him
he's a really good friend of mine he's a
great entrepreneur and you know maybe
he's got you know just even more courage
than i do because you know he's
investing like you know crazy amounts of
money but i think look he will be a big
winner long term fanduel is a great
company the offline casinos are good
companies i just think this is a perfect
fit into our platform and so um you know
i think we'll be very successful a long
time at it well i mean at least from
what i've heard the cost of acquisition
uh for gambling is obviously very very
high and you have acquired a lot of them
we require a customer for 19 bucks in
the commerce business and you know
average cost cost to acquire a customer
in in in uh you know online support
spends days 500 on a good day right so
you know i'd much rather you know i'd
much rather look at all this the
different places i can wire customers
then cross-sell them into online sports
betting then go out and spend 500 plus
you know and have a multi-year payback
that you know in a highly promotional
environment
well and so we're talking about this and
you brought up draftkings so thanks for
the the very uh good segue because you
actually gary do quite a bit with uh
draftkings um a prop betting show
uh so would love your perspectives do
you recommend everyone to bet on the
jets in the show every week
uh
not this season but with four picks in
the top 38 and with top five free agent
money and with a remarkable draft class
left who's a yes or no question the
answer is i'm more optimistic how much
money you've lost people on the jets in
the past
five or ten years uh happening in boston
with robert here let's just get this out
in the open i mean have you literally
cost your tens of millions of of people
who really depend on you have you cost
them hundreds of millions of dollars in
the jets i have not because if you watch
props and drops i've actually
decided to bet against the jets the
majority of this year
because it could be when it comes to
business some unemotional
as a fan i'm very emotional um so i
think i've made people money
just had to get that out all right so
yeah so you get back out you're giving
them a hard time on the jets okay we get
it um
you know what's happening with that
though you have to understand why it's
so remarkable to be a jets fan because
you learned to lose no because i think
you know it's very similar to the
framework that you just said for someone
not to think that they're gonna be the
biggest player in the business that
they're going after in a decade means
they've lost before they've started like
why wouldn't you
it's one thing for the fans in the crowd
to think something what do you think i
think one of the great things about
having real ambition like the amount of
super bowls i'm going to win when i buy
the jets
are going to come
directly from jokes like this on stage
these are chips on shoulders
chips on [ __ ] shoulders matter guys
when i say get one thing out there i
will bet on you for everything other
than when you suppose over the crafts
and the patriots sorry buddy i am going
to win super bowls when i buy the jets
and i'm going to play this clip and i'm
going to end it with [ __ ] you michael
rubin
well we should have a good wager that
goes before one of us is uh not on this
planet we'll see listen modern
technology like i'm i've got 60 more
years of damage
that's fair
all right well let's get back to
draftkings so
why did you want to get involved there's
a bet on draftkings right now will gary
win multiple super balls
all right that's how you should launch
your platform perfect
will you promote it for me 100 okay
great okay why did you get i'm going to
just draftkings hired vape cat
my my my agency vaynermedia back to like
the way we both think and probably why
we have friendship is
when i started vaynermedia 13 years ago
i was coming from the wine retail
business and i looked at madison avenue
and i said my god these guys and girls
have this all wrong they are completely
obsessed with potential reach
and
just delusion of where the internet is
about to take us and so i saw an
opportunity to create a business and
over the last 13 years we've built the
largest independent agency in the world
and that is just facts and so
draftkings rightly decided to hire
vaynermedia for marketing and you know
and then you know to to michael's point
that crew those founders they're just
good guys you know like jason really
knows his stuff and kalish and i really
hit it off because he loves to collect
stuff and i you know we started talking
through the business about collecting
cards and things that nature and then he
got very excited about the nft space and
we just decided to do a podcast
okay so then you know based on
everything in your experiences growing
uh properties what is your advice to
jason or amy howe at fanduel on how to
think about fanatics coming into this
space
they should be concerned because
the the reality is anytime you have a
like i have the most confidence that i'm
going to build the best xyz always but
to be
delirious and not understand the
competitive landscape is also a a
dangerous strategy and so i think
i believe that what michael is doing
is the preview to what many great
operators are going to do over the next
20 years because the way technology is
today it makes all the sense in the
world to go vertical and horizontal if
you are capable so and one thing i've
thrown there's i actually think it's a
really big space so there actually is
room for lots of great companies like
draftkings and fanduel that's not me
just being politically correct i really
feel that way and jason and i talk about
it all the time like this this a really
big space what we're looking forward to
is leveraging the structural advantages
that we have at fanatics to kind of
build you know kind of a more integrated
and you know kind of best experience for
the family you know what i mean it's
really global you don't have to be as
remarkable as jason to hear we're
acquiring customers at 12 bucks over
here and we're going to bring them over
here i mean
i don't you know some things are just
uncomfortably obvious but this isn't
about the strategy it's why michael i
mean i put out every strategy i have in
the world
publicly for free the second i come up
with it the reason do i do that is
because most people can't execute it
right so by the way and that takes
courage and it's funny
we come from the same mold from that
perspective i often
say what i'm going to do and i'm not
worried about it because i think we're
uniquely positioned to do it and by the
way sometimes that's wrong and you get
your foot in your mouth and you say god
i wish i would have kept my mouth shut
absolutely you know 99 of the time i'm
willing to tell people here's exactly
what we're going to do and here's our
script and you know we feel based on the
unique you know position of fanatics you
know we can do this better for the
sports fan and so other people don't
have that you know kind of inherent
advantages that we have
well i you know so
um i mean really insightful thank you
very much i think we were talking about
the jets for a second no it's a lifelong
dream of yours so you know you were kind
enough to give michael some advice on
his brand michael you have owned the
sixers for 11 years now what are the key
lessons i mean because i think it's
going to happen this guy is a force of
nature uh what are the key lessons that
you learned that you want to pass on to
gary if
if he actually goes on to own the jets
well first i'm one of um you know i'm
one of and one of several owners in the
group led by josh harris and david
blitzer a great partnership and we have
been at it now for 11 years i'd say the
biggest thing that i think a lot of
really smart
um
new owners get wrong
is they try to be overly involved versus
picking the right people to lead the
team we're fortunate enough to you know
this conference is started by you and
dower and we're fortunate enough to have
daryl leading our basketball
organization i think you know that's why
we're a much better basketball team this
year and you know i think to me um what
i've always taken the same
philosophy that i had in business and
applied to sports which is get the best
freaking people on the planet and then
get out of the way okay and only be
involved in the biggest decision and
daryl will say he'll call me he'll tell
me about some something about some
player i've never heard over something
i'm like daryl i don't care don't even
why are you telling me this because i
only care about the big things what do i
care about i care about having daryl
leading basketball i care about having
doc coach i care about having ted brown
as a ceo and i care about i mean you
know ownership stay out of the way other
than on the biggest and most strategic
decisions i think that's how you win and
that's actually not what a lot of new
owners do i and and i see a lot of new
owners you know they're super smart like
gary so they get in there they want to
be in the draft room and they want to be
you know dictating everything that
happens and you know what they do they
generally screw it up um so you know i'd
say if you're actually fortunate enough
one day to um you know own the jets i'd
say the biggest thing you want to do is
pick the best people be supportive of
them and not you know you know to try to
do their jobs for them because it never
works and the history of people trying
to do the jobs of the people that you
know they should be getting the best
people to do it it never works out
my my strategy is when you buy the team
i'm gonna i'm gonna be honest be honest
right now i'm gonna be the digital the
head coach and the starting wide
receiver perfect
no i think i honestly would you listen
yeah i mean by the way i'm actually more
comfortable in that zone as well
obviously you know
when you're as passionate you know i
haven't missed the play of the new york
jets game live no dvr [ __ ] since
1982. wow so this is like foundational
for me i was born in the former soviet
union i would argue that jets football
was my kind of like american moment it's
a very big part of my life
so the discipline required to do exactly
what michael's saying which is 100
the right blueprint i promised my
brother aj who's 11 years younger than
me and is going to absolutely be on this
journey with me i said listen i'm going
to do all that everything he just said
but i said but the one thing i'm gonna
need is i'm still gonna need to be able
to pick the seventh round pick i'm gonna
i'm keeping that yeah now the the one
thing i will tell you is is um
sports needs
owners like gary because that's the next
generation and for me i'm actually going
to a different place in my life people
ask me all the time i actually i'm 100
focused on fanatics i will not be you
know you know for me my only involvement
is the sixers i will not be doing
anything incremental um
for probably the next several decades if
it ever again in my life i'm 100 locked
into making fanatics you know the most
incredible digital sports platform in
the world i don't want any distractions
from that um but i actually think sports
does need great owners i think you know
if every league could have you know
incredible owners you know across the
board it's going to make it better for
the fan it's going to make it better for
the the players there's going to be more
money involved there's going to be
better product on the field on the court
on the ice so you know i love that gary
wants to you know own a football team or
own the jets in this case and you know i
think that you know the the sports
leagues can't have more you can't have
enough great owners
well so i think what you're saying is
the jets need an owner no i'm not saying
that at all um i'm just i'm just saying
i'm just saying that that i think gary
would be a good owner of a sports team
all right well i want to get me in
trouble like that i know what i was just
kidding um it's a good try though thanks
oh
one of uh one of the things that i
admire about both of you is um that you
have started so many different
businesses and in so many different
verticals
and so i'd love to get a little bit of
perspective what is the difference
between being a serial entrepreneur
versus a one-hit wonder
uh talent
like that's just real life like i think
you know first of all being a one-hit
wonder is something that should be
cheered more often i've had interactions
with a lot of people who've only had one
big business win or only had one hit
record like that's hard
that's hard i'm on a board of a company
yesterday we're talking about a
situation and
the outcome might not be as great but
the outcome is a 0.001
success so i think talent is one i also
think it's dna i think michael gave you
a really interesting insight to why
things work for him as an entrepreneur
around his content he said i can only do
things that feel comfortable i have so
many friends who've accomplished so much
more financially in business world who
always tell me that i do too many things
that i'm doing too many things you are
and and i say to them that's great if
your kpi is to maximize your financial
output my kpi is to maximize my
happiness yeah so but i'll debate that
for a second i'm more happy locked in
and focused right that's exactly right
right now focused on making next the
most incredible kind of remember that's
exactly right and i think that's amazing
um for me i need the creativity of doing
some other things alongside with my
cores i need the side dish i need the
moose boosh i need that that makes me
happier and so i think for everybody out
here
it's a game of self-awareness i think
people a lot of people only have one hit
because they try to run the same
blueprint they did the first time but
the world changes so i need you doing
multiple things too because you make me
smarter so the good thing if you go out
and figure it out and then you just help
me and that's what you know dumb guys
like me actually need help with so it's
perfect you know i'll tell you it's also
about what people want i was with
somebody over the holiday break who
started a company three or four years
later they sold it for 20 billion
dollars they less than 100 employees and
they said to me i don't want to do this
again like you know i'm i'm throwing
what i'm doing so you know for me i'm
going to work my ass off every day until
i die because i have fun that's what i'm
passionate about i wake up i go to bed
i'm excited i love the action i don't
know what i'd do if i didn't have it
like i would literally like i would be
like looking at my phone waiting for
action now and you know now i wake up
and go to bed exhaust every day and
because i have too much action so you
know it's all about how you're wired i
mean you know there are people you know
some people you know money is a
manufacturer i don't even care about
money i care about like winning
competing competing winning
entrepreneurs having fun learning and
you by the way
if you do care about money it will
always follow if you care about those
things if your main objective is like i
want to learn i want to grow i want to
compete you know innovate yeah you want
to innovate all that together the money
does always follow but i don't care
about it all i just care about like
maximizing every minute of every day
well pretty like-minded and very
successful folks that's great advice
i'm going to take questions from the
audience we we have had a lot of great
discussion so i think we're only going
to have time for one so
um you guys have both alluded to the
impact of the blockchain uh on sports
and so i think
that's a positive i would like to see
here
one area we've talked about ticketing so
put that one aside where you think it
could be used but also what is the
biggest threat right now to the sports
industry
biggest overall throughout our biggest
threat from blacks
go with the overall threat yes i'm
curious what you think yeah
um
look i think every industry changes
radically and um you know i think you
know
i think sports is the greatest
entertainment in the world but we got to
keep making it more relevant and we got
to keep keeping it fresh and innovative
and you know and
so you know for me i think it's you know
continue to innovate if you don't you
die and i think you know look things
that were relevant become less relevant
you can't take anything for granted so
i'd say the second you become complacent
sports i think you're you're dead and so
what i'd say is you got to keep pushing
on getting better changing evolving
better satisfying the fan i mean i look
every day i don't look at what we do
right i look at what we're doing wrong
like what can we do better so they get
to take that same mentality to it i
think there's something interesting
there though because i think the way i
would answer the question is similar to
macro micro we talked earlier about
blockchain versus nft projects
there's nothing threatening sports
and here's why if you look at the
history of man and woman that it is like
music and other aspects it's going to be
there forever the threats sit in the
micro
super bowl one did not sell out the 82
nba finals were on tape delay in america
esports is real
pickleball is taking market share from
tennis so the macro of sports is forever
the people that are vulnerable are the
people that just think their sport
boxing and horse racing and baseball
dominated 1945 and that's two seconds
ago and so what you see is complacency
when you're the league or the sport
that's dominating the day which is why
innovation comes along you know mma
versus boxing in 1978 in america which
is again five minutes ago is not even a
conversation the first one didn't even
exist so i think what you look at to
michael's point is there are a lot of
leagues at the top across the paradigm
of sports globally call in the top 25
that are incredibly vulnerable because
they are absolutely in a framework of
selfish behavior not selfless to the fan
innovation
and coming up with the times and i think
that's the more exciting thing to watch
play out over the next 20 years the
leagues that lose market share and the
leagues and personalities and sports
that emerge out of nowhere
amazing points across the board so this
i'm so sad that we're at the end of this
time because i really would want to talk
uh with you for much longer but i want
to bring it all back together at the end
a couple of the learnings from today the
nfts are gonna crash um you have to
create value extra value uh for when it
goes down for your fans so a huge focus
on relationships the fan
um you know authenticity being taking
advantage of the contract of the utility
taking advantage of the contract of the
utility
blending quantitative and qualitative
having patience it's going to take 10
years or so to figure it out
most people can't execute
and lastly have fun and learn
so thank you both so much for kicking
off sloan this has been an absolute
pleasure thank you
[Music]